le son du nord lance l'animatrice
vedette de fox news qui depuis quelques
jours s'en donnent à coeur joie avec les
nouvelles d'ottawa en charge et
brega moi
les gens au pouvoir au canada ont
provoqué cette explosion dit elle à
cause de leurs restrictions sanitaire
tout en écorchant au passage le premier
ministre justin trudeau
le parti libéral est pris avec ce petit
chutera vacciner dit elle qui n'aime pas
voir d'autres gars ont joué dans son
carré de sable
c'est que le mouvement des camionneurs
canadien est récupéré par la droite
républicaine et c'est d'homme à homme
qui a parti le bal des dix jours
les camionneurs canadien dit il résiste
courageusement à la vaccination illégal
le sénateur telle clause a renchéri
ce sont des héros dit il des patriotes
qui manifestent pour notre liberté elle
ferma fil du temps d'ailleurs un ancien
fidèle de donald chambre prend là
d'exane de l' semble faire partie des
organisateurs canadiens
l'aude one son conseiller en santé sous
l'administration de chambre tenté à
l'époque de minimiser la pandémie et
prôner l'unité de groupe
ces manifestations vont maintenant au
delà des mesures sanitaire souligne la
porte-parole de la maison blanche de
perdre un mouvement inquiétant soutient
cet ancien stratège république a permis
aux martys il y à des groupes néo nazis
qui ont des liens avec l'extrême droite
américaine dit il sur les deux côtés de
la frontière et sans honneur et sans pub
et c'est nouveau et dangereux ajoutent
ils mais sur les réseaux sociaux
d'autres convois s'organise aux états
unis
je soutiens font ce qu'ils ont fait au
canada 17 organisateurs un mouvement qui
prend de l'ampleur partout dans le monde
maman nouvelle zélande la cause des
camionneurs canadien a fait écho
ici le mouvement d'ici qu'on ne voit et
qui compterait cent cinquante mille
membres prévoient organiser un convoi
qui ré de la californie à la capitale
américaine d'ici le 1er mars ici à des
bordelais guerguisse radio-canada
washington